It's the miracle of life… you get to a certain
age and your biological clock kicks in, your
mom starts calling you and pestering you for
grandbabies...
It's the 21st century… are we still victims
of the biological need to Fam Up?
babies
Inside our brain is the hypothalamus and inside
that is the supra-chiasmatic nucleus, a small
grouping of brain cells which make sure our
metabolism, hormones, body temperature, and
sleep/wake cycle stay on beat.
Biological clocks are an example of convergent
evolution, as plants, fungi, animals and cyanobacteria
all seem to have some kind of clock.
Flowers need to know when to open, close,
or release fragrance; deciduous trees need
to know when to pop buds or drop leaves -- and
humans have a biological clock telling us
when it’s time to bear our own fruit, so
to speak.
When we're not talking about our daily biological
clock, usually people mean when are you having
the babies?
But is that a biological clock too?
Or just a social one?
The puberty clock is a mysterious beast.
A June 2015 study in the Proceedings of the
National Academy of Scientists found after
puberty set in, the set of neurons in the
mammalian brain which tell the body when to
release sex hormones.
Meaning, scientists have found the switch
that tells our sex organs when to make eggs
and sperm… and as time marches on, fertility
begins to diminish.
According to a study in Human Reproduction,
the late 20s are the strongest biological
clock years for women.
After 27 the chances of becoming pregnant
during any one menstrual cycle declines slowly,
and after 35 rates have dropped 40 percent;
basically, it's almost twice as difficult
to get pregnant after 35 than at 19.
Which explains that oft-reported late-20s
biological tick-tock; the body is saying,
“You’re running out of time!
Do it now!”
But it's not just them ladies, y'all.
Men have a biological clock too.
For most of the history of modern medicine,
women have been the focus of infertility,
but in the last two to three decades, the
spotlight has been on men too.
As men age, their sperm volume and quality
decreases (we've talked about this on DNews
before, as our subscribers know).
And a 2008 study in Nature found of 100,000
men studied, offspring of those over 40 had
a 475 percent increase in autism spectrum
disorder, in comparison to those under 30.
One would think, if it was biological, the
clock would kick in near the end of your ability
to safely have babies.
And by studying In-vitro fertilization treatments,
McGill University found 43 and a half was
the crossover age for males with or without
offspring; suggesting the tick-tock was strongest
in the late 30s; and just like with the ladies,
your body is yelling at you to get a move
on!
So, since it would seem biological baby fever
is real, what about emotional?
According to one 2011 study in Emotion, both
men and women experience the "fever."
They explored it from three angles 1. we are
trained by society to have babies; 2. we have
a need to nurture; or 3. we adapt to babies
through our exposure.
Using surveys with (an admittedly) small dataset,
neither needing to nurture nor social pressure
explained baby fever as strongly as the adaptational
view.
According to their findings, "positive exposure
to babies" made people want to have kids,
but "negative exposure," loud infants who
cry, or stink, made people shy away.
They conclude people's positive and negative
experiences are weighed by their subconscious,
and that flips our biological baby switch.
As expected, baby fever is a combination of
subconscious concerns over viable offspring
and positive life experiences for both men
and women.
If you’re around babies, you wants one.
As men garner more focus from the scientific
community you we can all look forward feeling
the pressure from… wait… hang on…
Interestingly, the researchers from the Emotional
study found something else… after the first
kid, women's self-rated baby fever dropped,
whereas men's rose.
The researchers guess women’s baby fever
was somehow satisfied, and perhaps men wanted
to spread their seed even more after their
first success?
As we usually say, more research is needed.
exits
What do you think?
Do you feel the tick tock of the biological
clock?
Pressure from Mom?
Dad?
Tell us about it in the comments.
For more on the brain's mysterious biological
clock, check out this video Anthony did where
he explores how our biological clock gets
alll screwed up (soundup).
ALSO Live Show?